hey guys welcome to ask i J it's almost
Christmas so this is gonna be a festive
well Christmas ask IJ episode I planned
on getting a Christmas hat but I forgot
and Here I am Christmas hatless ya gotta
question on your mind don't be afraid
that any time cuz iced tea is ready for
you with your favorite song
very good question hmm paper snowflake
making skills I'm pretty sure mine are
non-existent do I believe in Santa Claus
of course I mean obviously who's gonna
bring me presents playstation move for
Xbox Kinect okay so originally I was
saying the playstation move but now i'm
not gonna lie after playing with the
Xbox Kinect I'm convert hmm connect all
the way my favorite thing about the
holidays is Christmas cookies and here's
a little picture let my sister sent me
from home while they were making
Christmas cookies she made me a little a
J mr. Jordan buzz or woody oh but of all
these questions that's probably one of
the most difficult I mean because buzz
lightyear is pretty freaking awesome
within woody is pretty freaking awesome
too what do you guys think Buzz
Lightyear or woody why am i upside down
I really don't know I'm not sure maybe
it's because I'm a really great editor
and I'm able to flip this video footage
in Final Cut Pro michael lucas one wants
to know what i want for business but
since i already told you guys that I'm
gonna answer your second question my
Christmas plans are to just visit family
and pretty much for a solid week and a
half I plan on playing video games with
my sister the entire time we're gonna
non-stop be sitting on a couch gaming
out of control so I plan to blog a lot
more on youtube.com slash other iJustine
I'm going to try to vlog every day from
the time that I get home until I leave
which I don't know how long that's gonna
be so yeah MJ k to 12 wants to know if I
like colored lights white Christmas
dates I feel like I like the colored
ones a little bit more because it's a
little more
tria cresting sung by a girl the best
thing to do about the haters just ignore
him am 11 14 my most memorable thing
about college is probably spending
pretty much the entire time in the
computer lab working and working
non-stop yes I'm definitely looking
forward to 2011 what is your new year's
resolution Elliot 1301 says just in case
you Christians ask IJ episode list your
favor Christmas song pretty sure I just
said in a previous video that I don't
have a favorite person song but I mean
if I have to pick one up no jingle bells
I mean come on you just can't go wrong
with jingle bells no I have not been to
Europe to I reshoot my ask IJ videos in
to have any bloopers normally I have so
many bloopers that it takes me a solid
hour just to go through and find the
good parts of the videos that I didn't
mess up my favorite favorite food
phrases far raised s I can't talk today
Facebook resting Stephanie wants to know
if I like the movie elf and what one of
my favorite phrases is so there's a few
issues here number one I've never seen
the movie elf should probably get that
taken care of and number two since I
haven't seen the movie I can't tell you
what my favorite phrase is favorite
Christmas movie most people will respond
to this as saying oh the Christmas story
is my favorite movie i'm pretty sure
that i am the only person left on this
planet that has actually not seen the
personal story ok i take that back on my
sister's actually haven't seen the
Christmas story either and i'm not sure
why it's one of those things that every
Christmas its plays over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again they always change the channel
because I don't want to watch it ashley
wants to know what i want for christmas
um actually I don't really want anything
for Christmas so I take that back I
really want a sweet xbox headset so when
I'm playing call of duty wouldn't be the
coolest kid on the block speaking of
Christmas presents if you guys want to
get me Christmas present this year you
can check out my charity water or /
awesome and donate to build an awesome
well now we've already built one well
and probably by the time I post this
video will it build two wells and on to
the third so check it out that's what
you can get me for Christmas
yeah okay next question do I have any
pets no how's my eye um it's healing
it's healing slowly but surely I can
meet aliens what would I tell them I
probably wouldn't tell them anything I
would probably be asking a lot of
questions for one what are you doing
here you guys for watching this episode
of ask IJ I will see you guys in the
next episode for the time being don't
forget to check out my other YouTube
channels and be sure to subscribe see
you guys later
you
Oh